I get it you're so mature you're so
smart
wait let me say that again you're so
erudite you have huge ideas about the
nature of mankind and the inner
suffering we all endure petty stuff it
really is but it really kill you to
crack a smile a wise man once said the
key to unlocking the human heart is
through laughter granted that man with
me and no one has called me wise without
smirking but there's some truth in that
no games have become so somber so
desperate to filter their killing sprees
through a lens of philosophical intrigue
that the simple joy of silly Follies has
dissipated in the ether enter Earth
Defense Force 2025 aliens have invaded
our planet and they brought giant
insects with them
it's everyone's worst nightmare brought
to life spiders the size of eight-legged
tractors bees that could swallow
moby-dick whole and Dragons while the
dragons are normal-sized if dragons were
normal and so you blast them to
smithereens watch as their lifeless
bodies soar through the air crowd like a
frightened puppy when one catches you in
a - biting Maw limbs and thorax is
everywhere alien ships raining down
reinforcements buildings crumbling like
stale cake and everyone's screaming with
glee tinged with misery the insects are
killing everything that makes us human I
mean just look at all this destruction
well I actually blew up all those
buildings so don't look at that and all
the civilians ran to safety huh so maybe
the aliens aren't causing as much harm
as at humans but who cares are you
really going to take very side
enemy is not damaged
classes separate the fliers from the fly
knots wing diver who is totally not
paling flies like a helicopter that's
dangerously low on fuel watch me soar
and shoot before plummeting back to
earth the fencer is not a fleet footed
swordsman but a brutish bully with a
heart of stone or some other hard
substance brick whatever the air Raider
is smart enough to ask for
reinforcements and the Ranger well he's
remarkable and his unremarkable miss
have you ever seen anything like ETF
2025 well maybe if you played any of the
previous Earth Defense Force games then
I'm gonna get a whole lot more of that
chaotic pleasure
but did that damper my enthusiasm not as
much as you think
EDF separates itself from other games by
being so gosh-darn different from
everything else out there
it's Robotron meet starship troopers in
a world striving to be the next Citizen
Kane remember when such oddball
experiences were the norm run one store
shelves were lined with war of the
monsters or Shadows of the Damned or
lollipop chainsaw what happened don't
get me wrong I do love thoughtful
ruminations that show how far games have
come from when I first started playing
but should there be more palate
cleansers out there something outside of
the indie scene that makes me laugh like
a kid I hereby appoint myself the head
of the silly Council until I discover a
solution turn your guns towards that
giant spider and wish it a good trip
you